American basketball star Brittany
Greiner has been released from a Russian
penal colony through a prisoner exchange
she's safe she's on a plane she's on her
way home after months being unjustly
detained in Russia the deal traded
Greiner for Russian arms dealer Victor
Boot and capped a months-long ordeal
that included the two-time Olympians
detainment a drug trial and negotiations
that culminated with a dramatic Cold War
style Handover in Abu Dhabi
Griner who played in Russia during the
WNBA offseason was detained at a Moscow
area airport in mid-February for
carrying Vape cartridges with hashish
oil in her luggage according to Russian
officials on May 3rd the state
department declared that Greiner was
being wrongfully detained putting the
weight of the U.S government behind the
campaign for her release Brittany
Greiner should not be detained she she
should not be detained for a single day
longer on July 1st about four and a half
months after Griner was detained Russian
prosecutors outlined the drug charges
against her the Basketball Star pleaded
guilty to the charges on July 7 hoping
to secure a more lenient sentence
according to her lawyers and speaking
through a Russian translator during a
hearing on July 27th Griner apologized
for what she said was an honest mistake
do not
never getting a little stretch a couple
of years
on August 4th Griner was convicted of
bringing marijuana into Russia with
Criminal Intent I hope that
in your ruling that it doesn't end my
life here she was sentenced to nine
years in prison an outcome that was
expected to clear the way for
negotiations between the U.S and Russia
over her release I am
determined to get her home and get her
home safely the campaign for greiner's
release put a spotlight on the inner
workings of prisoner diplomacy in both
the U.S and Russian governments
President Biden is personally engaged on
this I am personally engaged on this we
are dealing with the Russians at very
senior levels leaders of the United Arab
Emirates and Saudi Arabia conducted the
mediation efforts for the settlement The
Exchange freed Russian arms dealer
Victor boot nicknamed The Merchant of
death
boot has spent the last 10 years in a
U.S prison after being convicted of
trying to sell weapons to Colombian
Rebels
as many celebrated the release of
Brittany Greiner some lawmakers shifted
Focus to Paul Whalen an American
Security contractor who has been held by
Russia since 2018 on Espionage charges
this was not a choice of which American
to bring home
the choice was one
or none U.S officials said that Russia
had rejected all of the Biden
administration's proposals for weyland's
release while we have not yet succeeded
in securing Paul's release we are not
giving up
foreign